what's going on guys this is rob we're
back with invincible yes we
are and where the last video that we did
was kind of it was okay for what it was
this one's a lot more interesting right
this is a lot more intriguing that's one
of the funny things about invincible
is once it kind of starts to build and
then you get in like the post omni man
era
there's like one or two stories where
things are a little murky and then it
just takes off right like i've been
saying especially when you get to the
filter my war that's when things are
super cool
right but there's a couple things that
go on here and one of the things that i
want to talk about is kind of the
aftermath of everything that happened
with omniman and one of the things that
plays out here is that with
mark continuing its role as a superhero
that's kind of out there doing his thing
and because the whole surveillance
footage of mark and omniman fighting was
leaked basically the world being aware
of the fact that mark is the son of omni
man then in turn
it's kind of like this press conference
this that's basically done here
and is one of the things where one part
of it is information gathering right the
public's just curious but the other part
is the public's a little bit scared
right because like
a man tried to conquer the world and his
son is still here they don't know what
the deal is
they don't really know what's going on
and so more kind of being out here and
and talking about what his dad did the
fact that omni man was
really here for the purpose of
conquering the world the power he
possessed things like that
it's really more of just trying to kind
of try to reassure the public and simply
saying like i'm doing this because i
believe i'm doing the right thing now
while the public is coming at it from
two directions so is mark the first part
is really mark just kind of being a good
guy here and just saying look like this
is
really where i'm coming from but the
second is because as most of you guys
know fear gives way to terrible things
and human beings are nothing if not a
fearful race
and so the response to the fear of
omniman and the threat he represented
would then turn into
other superheroes well can we trust them
are they inherently good people do we
have to worry about them trying to
conquer the world and things along those
lines so mark whether he knows it or not
is kind of doing double duty here and is
really kind of standing out in front of
the general public and saying look
like i'm doing what i'm doing because i
genuinely believe it's the right thing
and the hope is that because of who he
chooses to associate himself with
they're in the same train of thought as
well now we as the reader know they are
i mean the guardians of the globe really
kind of solidify that like not every
hero out there is there to attack people
but like the first thing a hysterical
person says
is i'm not hysterical meaning people are
not inherently logical right we are
emotional first
logical second and so because of that
it's one of these things where you kind
of have to approach it from that
perspective and it's smart for mark to
do that
the second thing that goes on here and
this is kind of a little bit of a
subplot in the sense that kirkman was
kind of building up to it and it's going
to become something more significant
later on down the line mark's younger
brother's developing powers which is
awesome i mean we
kind of knew it was only a matter of
time the insectoid race that his mother
comes from does not inherently have
powers the powers he's getting he
inherited from omniman right which is
kind of a cool thing to see and it's
really mark's first time
in seeing him being able to fly the big
concern here is that once this
revelation
is presented to deborah right at mark's
mom how is she going to respond to it
and when she learns that
essentially omni kid is what we can kind
of call him because he basically learns
how to fly
or at least demonstrates the ability to
fly then it turns into a kind of
conversation where it's
this is dangerous now this is kind of a
funny thing about this is it'd be very
easy for us to approach this from the
perspective that mark's mom
is just being overprotective and she
doesn't want her son to become like
omniman and because she still struggles
with him she's basically projecting that
onto her kid
that's not necessarily the case here one
of the things that she kind of talks
about
it's one of the things that's kind of
nipped in the bud right off the bat when
mark brings it up is she kind of talks
about how this this whole thing is
he's so young and while he is aging
pretty fast
and he is intelligent at the end of the
day he's still a kid and what kid who
has powers or even what kid in general
under you know really really grasps and
understands what it means to be in
danger right like
a kid running out in the street to chase
a ball that's a perfect example of that
and so because kids usually just kind of
act first and then think second
it's one of these things where she kind
of has to safeguard him this is
important because it's really debra kind
of looking at this kid very much as her
own child
but at the same time because mark was
older and because mark had his father
to guide him this kid doesn't
necessarily have that while mark could
offer some sort of guidance here and in
fact he will over time
the important thing is mark is still
learning about himself and mark's still
figuring his powers out
mark's not nearly as confident or even
as old and experienced
as his father was and so because of that
he can't quite bring that kind of wisdom
to the table and so quite literally
mark and this kid are essentially flying
by the seat of their pants now in the
midst of all this as you have a counter
conversation taking place between the
immortal and cecil cecil essentially
picks up on a kind of projectile that's
headed towards earth
and appears to be sentient and that it
might be some kind of an attack now this
is really more of just kind of
cecil sort of figuring out or talking
out loud as he's learning about this but
the immortal takes it as gospel truth
and immediately goes in attacks
only for us to find out it's out on the
ailing now the funny thing about this is
we know alan the alien would crush the
immortal and not even by a little bit
right it would be an
absolute devastating situation and so in
response to the immortal taking off
mark's contacted and mark goes and tries
to intervene which he successfully does
right he kind of gets between the
immortal and alan the alien
and it's one of these things where marx
is kind of like okay look like i know
this whole telepathy thing only works
both ways so it's not as though like i'm
a conduit and you can talk to the
immortal through me or anything along
those lines it's one of these things
where alan the alien seems to be able to
have the ability to pick and choose who
can hear his telepathic thoughts which
makes sense that's that's
kind of par for the course when it comes
to telepathy but he kind of talks to
mark about hey here like i'm i'm here to
see you i'm not really here to see the
immortal this guy just kind of freaked
out and attacked me and mark's like yeah
man he's kind of been through a lot and
that kind of a thing and so it's kind of
funny because when everything kind of
starts to calm down the immortal
apologizes and he's like i didn't hurt
you did i and alan's like no
not one bit not even a little bit
don't worry man i'm not worried about
you hurting me
like i promise i'll be okay he doesn't
really say it in so many words
but i mean come on right like the
immortal's cool and everything
but you know he's just not on the same
level right it's just it's just not
there in terms of the ability to take
on even mark or alan the alien and so
once they get back to mark's dorm room
mark kind of spills the beans and so
does allen alien and that's one of the
things where mark's basically told like
i was
basically asked by by thaddeus the
leader of the coalition of planets to
bring you back to telescria right
because you and your father present the
only real known instances that we're
aware of outside of thaddeus himself
where a vulture might has defected from
the empire
now with mark it's a little bit
different of a situation just because he
was raised along earthlings and so he
wasn't really indoctrinated
full-on into the viltrumide ideology
like his father was
but it was really kind of kirkman sort
of hitting at the nature of people that
yeah we screw stuff up more than we get
things right but at the end of the day
like
humanity is kind of infectious right
empathy different things like that
and it changed omniman and so really
omniman's a big talking point here right
omniman was a full-blown vulture mind
who lived among the empire for
decades and decades and decades and
hundreds and thousands of years and so
because of that
the fact that he defected the fact that
he left the velcro mite empire
and sided with with earthlings and
ultimately took on you know took on a
different planet instead of just like
setting earth up to be conquered was
kind of mind-blowing and it's something
that we just didn't really expect
it's something that not even the
villager might expected or even like
thaddeus expected it's just it's one of
those things that's just unheard of when
you're a viltromite
you're a viltromite right like you
follow the ideology and so mark actually
presents uh alan with the books that his
father left behind for now in the last
video we did we talked about how these
books were written by omni man written
by nolan for the purpose
of basically lining out how to defeat
the viltromites right they were written
under the guise of like science fiction
but they were basically artifacts and
weapons that exist
and while allen's experience in space
and in escapades across the universe is
not it's probably not on the same level
as
thaddeus and in fact it actually is not
he has enough experience to know the
things that are written in this book
they they're real they exist right
they're actual things that exist
out there now when the offer is extended
to mark to join
alan on on telescreen mark's like no
that's not going to happen right i've
got too much going on like i'm failing
my classes
i just broke up with my girlfriend like
my my younger brother just developed
powers i got things i need to focus on
here
and it's one of these things where
there's not a whole lot of animosity
right it's not as though alan the
alien's like oh you're coming
to telescreen you know whether i have to
bring you conscious or unconscious
it's not necessarily like that it's just
one of those things where it's kind of
like okay you know like i'll
it would be disappointing you could make
it but you know i'll let uh i'll let
sadios know that you didn't show up here
the other thing that happens
is that while mark's hanging out with
william suddenly eve comes busting in
and she's like so i heard that you're
single now
are we gonna bang or what and like
that's the woman you want man
that's the kind of girl you want that's
the kind of woman you want man
one who speaks her mind like that's
that's the kind you want right who tells
you what she's thinking
you don't want the kind of girls who
like play games and they expect you to
figure stuff out and things like that
i don't have the time or the energy for
that that's the kind of girl you want
that's why i love mariah one of the
reasons why i love my eyes so much well
that's the thing you want right like a
girl who just tells you what she's
thinking but one of the things that kind
of goes on is like adam eve just full-on
reveals everything and it really kind of
talks about how her interest in mark
went back quite some way but at the time
she was with rex so it was kind of one
of those hey look i'm not gonna make a
move on you while i'm with somebody else
and then ultimately once rex cheated on
her then like all bets were off right
she was like okay like we're done
and then she started gunning for mark
but the crazy thing was mark ended up
with amber at almost that exact same
time and so
it was one of those things where it was
just kind of like you know he was tied
up then she was tied up and then he was
tied up and so on and they just couldn't
quite get the mark at the same time the
funny thing about this is
mark knew all this right like amber
spilled the beans on it all and
adam eve was just kind of i mean you
already you already knew all this and
he's like yeah
we know mark knew all this because he
saw the future version of adam e and she
revealed the whole thing to him and so
he's kind of like yeah like i saw a
future version of of yourself
you know and and she'd been obsessed
with me right all these years
because i never really gave her an
answer i never really told her whether
or not we were going to get together i
always kind of beat around the bush
never quite made time for anything like
that and that's kind of how he knows and
it's kind of a funny thing you know
because it's
it's almost like they treat that version
of adam eve as a totally different
person and so one of the things like
with that kind of big revelation coming
out she sort of asked like are you are
you in
are we entertaining this conversation
because you feel sorry for me because
you don't want me to become that old
lonely bitter version of myself is that
why all this is happening and mark
doesn't know i mean i guess he says
no he's like you know i don't i don't
think i'm doing that doing it for that
reason and that right there that lack of
certainty
is enough to put adam eve on the path of
believing that's actually the case
right mark's like this he's having this
conversation with her because he feels
bad for her and that's not what anybody
wants to hear right nobody wants to be
to have like a pity party thrown for
them by somebody else right especially
when it comes to matters of the heart
and so because of that you kind of
switch over to mark the next day
spending time with his mom right he was
kind of told that he's guaranteed to
fail his classes and honestly marx is
considering dropping out of school
because he gets paid more working for
cecil than he would ever have working a
real job and the reality isn't really
see
a necessity for it the thing that ends
up happening though is he's basically
met by the arrival of a female
viltromite now she will become very
important later on down the line for
reasons that are pretty screwed up and
people who are read invincible are just
like yes
it was very screwed up it was very
messed up but like she becomes important
later on down the line right the
important thing that goes on here
is she basically threatens mark with
killing his mom if mark doesn't go with
her right so he ends up meeting her
about two miles up in about a minute and
they kind of have this bit of a
conversation and one of the things that
goes on here
is is it's really her as a vulture might
almost appealing to mark's better sense
right in the in the idea of saying like
filter viltrumites we as a race are not
inherently desiring to destroy people
right we're looking to expand our empire
but we're not inherently
looking for violence right we're not
arbitrarily violent we invoke violence
when we need to right violence is not
always the answer but it is a
answer and it's a very effective answer
right violence gets things done and so
because of that
one of the things that she kind of hits
on here is this world that you live in
here right this world you live on this
this world
earth home of humanity is plagued by
like illness and disease
and violence and like inequality and all
that kind of stuff like this world
sucks and there's literally no reason
anybody of your caliber
should be here what are you protecting
right like what are you what are you
saving these people from
right i mean you're not saving them from
anything tangible i mean sure there's a
few villains here and there but in the
grand scheme of your race's history
these villains won't really amount for
anything so you're saving humanity for a
day
and you're dooming it for a lifetime so
what what are you what are you looking
to save here like we as the vulture
might from the other hand
sure we'll conquer this world but will
also bring a level of peace and
prosperity
it's never experienced before we'll make
it a utopia sure they'll lose their
freedom in the process
but how valuable could the freedom of
humanity possibly be if this is where
their freedom brought them to right to
a world of inequality and disease war
violence
like sure they have freedom and they've
used it to screw the world up so
we're gonna take that away right and
it's one of these things where mark's
kind of like no
and this is the argument that we've had
so many times before on this youtube
channel and it's one of those debates
that i love to have
right like i mean i guess the the
benefit of freedom is that it gives
humanity the ability to look at its past
mistakes and correct those without the
the yoke of oppression i guess but
humanity in his current form has been
around for something like 200
000 years right i guess the age of
industrialization didn't really begin
until the 1800s the point that i'm
making here is we've had time
so if we were going to fix ourselves we
would have
basically people don't want to and so
it's one of these things where it's kind
of like
yeah like she's not necessarily wrong
right i mean you know and that's that's
what that's what makes it so interesting
is because mark kind of responds so like
the whole point is you would be making
slaves complacent
until you basically suck this planet
drive and the response of of her
is i mean yeah we're going to kind of
destroy the world but your humanity will
have a few hundred years
of peace and prosperity on a level
they've never experienced before
and in turn maybe they can make
something out of themselves
maybe over the course of that couple
hundred years they can achieve
interstellar travel who really knows but
whatever the case is
yeah and so that's that's why it's kind
of interesting here right because it's
like on one hand you have a free society
who has used that freedom
to make the world into a cesspool and
then on the other hand you have somebody
showing up who's saying we're gonna
strip freedom away from society so
they're gonna live under our
authoritarian rule but you're also going
to have peace and prosperity in a way
that you've never had it before and i
know people will say well no freedom is
most important but like i mean what are
you really getting out of it right like
i mean what like how is your life better
now and so it's kind of interesting in
that way right the philosophical
argument that goes into that
is pretty fantastic and it's really
really cool and so ultimately it's one
of these things where mark's like okay
fine then let's see what you're about
like if you tell me that you really are
compassionate towards humanity that
you're not going to be some abusive
dictating race then show me then show me
what kind of a person you are right like
come with me on superhero escapades now
the reality of this
is on one hand while mark doesn't
necessarily say it it looks like it's
kind of done from the desire to actually
turn her to his cause right to actually
you know have the same effect on her
that earth had on his father the big
difference is that nolan lived on earth
for years and it took quite some time
for it to get to that point and even
then by the time he got to the final
battle between mark and nolan he still
wasn't necessarily swayed by humanity as
a whole it was his relationship with his
son that swayed him towards
basically abandoning earth and taking up
residence on a different planet instead
one of the things to understand here
when it comes to nolan sure he left
earth and he didn't pave the way for the
vulture mice to conquer it but there was
nothing about the conversation he had
with his son in that final battle
where it was humanity has changed my
view i believe the earth is a place to
save i'm going to stay here i'm going to
do everything i can to show that i'm
actually a good guy and when the vulture
might come which they will i'm going to
fight side by side with you and protect
the world no no he was like
leave this world and come with me or
help me conquer this world right like it
was only because mark loved his father
so much and vocalized that and the
the relationship between mark and his
dad that nolan left earth right so
that's an important distinction to
understand
the point that i'm making when i say
that is this girl's been here for 15
minutes
there's no way mark's gonna change her
mind
and that's exactly what happens when
she's just like so what do you say are
you gonna work with us and he's like no
i'm still not convinced and she's like
fine this is not a negotiation and just
starts like starts pummeling him right
just absolutely thrashes this guy and
it's really kind of designed to show
again where mark resides with regards to
the other vulture mites who are out
there and so she essentially tells him
here's the deal right like you have been
deemed a failure of a protector of this
world in the name of the vulture might
empire you're part viltromite which
means you operate under the service of
us and because of the fact that you have
essentially abandoned your post among
the viltrumites and you're remaining on
this world standing against the empire
a replacement will be sent and when that
time comes either you can agree to stand
beside us and the replacement will be
recalled or you can continue to stand
against us and the replacement will kill
you and then get the world ready for
conquering for the vulture might empire
either way
you got some period of time and she
doesn't give him a definitive time frame
she says it could be like five months or
five years right it could be any number
of things but like a replacement will be
sent and so the the reality of this is
mark kind of responds by like okay
i like i have to get ready for this
right i have to prep for this if this is
just
one viltromite and they're gonna send
some kind of replacement after me who
may very well be as strong or stronger
than her then i have to be ready for
that right mark has kind of shown time
and time again that while he's got the
fortitude and the desire to face off
against the viltrumites at the end of
the day he doesn't have the same kind of
experience or the same strength level
they have and so he's gotta beef himself
up right now
while that goes on alan the alien after
having left you know mark behind on
earth kind of starts traveling back to
telesco and is passed by a vulture might
ship and in hoping that they had noticed
him they ended up doing that and so he
ends up facing off against this same
vulture my woman that had interrogated
mark where it had met mark on earth now
the funny thing about this
is that as the two of them are fighting
she kind of talks about this idea
that because of the power he possesses
and so on because he refused to stand
for the vulture might empire but like so
many other people they've come across
who refuse to bend the knee that he'll
be executed and first and foremost he'll
be taken to a villager my prison and
that's when he recalls the conversation
he had with mark where mark had revealed
his father had been taken
and he was going to be executed and
that's when allen's like that's my
ticket right that's my ticket to get a
hold of nolan and so ultimately he kind
of goes in a fight and then plays possum
right she goes in for a punch and then
he's like oh my god you got right and it
just kind of makes it look like he's
knocked out
she snatches him up takes him aboard the
ship and he's basically taken to the
same place that mark is and that's kind
of a great thing there is because what
you end up doing is actually
transitioning to the filter mike prison
planet
a really prison asteroid uh where you
have nolan and nolan kind of struggling
and dealing with all this internal these
internal emotional issues that he's had
to cope with comes this kind of
realization
that he misses his wife on earth that
nolan at least on an emotional level
is becoming human more and more with
each passing day right with each passing
experience
as he thinks back on his life on earth
it's really nostalgia that kind of gets
the gets the better of him right this
idea of looking back to the life that he
lived looking back to his time
in that world raising mark his time with
his wife all the experiences he had what
it meant to live among humanity to be so
perfect among imperfect beings has
really just sort of
brought him to a place where he misses
that companionship he misses the
connection that he had with his wife and
so the result of this is a couple things
go on one of the first things that
happens is you have mark who actually
meets with cecil and basically all the
government guys who have more or less
constructed this gigantic hydraulic
press
right and mark's essentially using it to
try to bench press and increase his
weight
now like most filter mites as he gets
into conflicts and as he pushes himself
in the most extreme
he recovers at seemingly an exponential
rate right we don't really get a kind of
mathematical comparison so it's not as
though for every one battle and every
beating and so it's not as though
if on a scale of like one to ten the
beating he received is on
is is like a nine and so his strength
increases proportionally to that
particular beating that he got but we're
not really given any kind of of
explanation in that way it's simply
enough that he
his strength increases exceedingly fast
right and he's exceedingly capable
in that way and so following that what
you have here is nolan who almost tries
to instigate this kind of prison break
right tries to break out of this filter
my prison and in doing so
of course he's ultimately captured by
general crick and general craig
basically beats him within an inch of
his life and they drag him back to
himself but when that happens
alan is also brought on board the ship
right and that's when alan tells him
telepathically we'll have a conversation
later
you and i will talk later and that's one
of the things where basically it's
setting the stage for this idea that
alan the alien and nolan
are gonna end up teaming up and then
ultimately we're gonna see what road
that takes for nolan and i'm gonna tell
you right now the story of omniman
following the time he leaves earth
is amazing but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
uh thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later peace